so during the  the tickets to my downfall tour we had  i think it was less than 10 days to pull  a bunch of stuff together it's going  down downfalls high school last day of  the movie let's go  the past year  work-wise  i did four movies  directed and wrote one of them  yeah  i wrote and published a graphic novel  like red lipstick or what like that i  went to italy and curated the soundtrack  to a dolce gabbana fashion show live and  also walked in the show at the same time  came out with my own nail polish line  called undone  i showed up to rehearsals  and then realized  i just [ __ ] off the biggest  opportunity for me as a musician ever  and finally you're telling me that this  tour just sold out and like i forgot to  build a set  he showed up 72 hours before we were  actually scheduled to play the first  show  we didn't prepare for [ __ ]